After stopping Joe Tipin's protocol by BUN and creatinine are finally back in range.
Yay! But my chloride is slightly high. Okay, so what would cause chloride to go up?
So chloride is going to go up with metabolic acidosis or adrenal stress. So those are the two
things that are going to cause chloride to go up. Your globulid is slightly low. Well,
globulid is not going to really try to chloride. So one of the ways you could develop, okay, what
is it? It's metabolic acidosis or adrenal stress. Well, you have to look at other factors too,
remember? We'll just look at it in clues. Typically you're going to have an increased chloride levels.
With adrenal stress, you're going to have increased chloride levels associated with adrenal
hyperfunction. Meaning like you're at a lot of stress right now, your adrenals are really kicking
out. So that adrenal exhaustion. So there's a difference with adrenal stress and adrenal exhaustion.
You also have to consider it's adrenal stress. If your chloride levels are increased
along with your, many times your sodium will be increased and you haven't slightly decreased
in potassium because you're birdied through potassium with your adrenal stress.
If it's metabolic acidosis, you could have increased chloride with a decreased CO2
along with an increased chloride and an increased, what's called an aniam gap.
That's the difference. That's the separation between your anions. You're positively,
negatively charged minerals. So those are the kinds of things that you could have balanced that out.
You're estimated on a very low, the filtration rate regularly low
around 72. Well, I'd have to look at the rest of your blood work as well because remember all
these things just compare to one another.